it was completely predictable that this
was going to happen and it is Donald
Trump as I told you yesterday proposed a
25% steel tariff and a 10 percent
aluminum tariff and the European Union
is now proposing a retaliatory tariffs
of 25 percent on a bunch of different
goods produced in the United States and
this would hurt American products in
European markets right this is how it
works and as a chain reaction as a
subsequent effect it would hurt American
businesses and the list of goods so far
would be limited to shirts jeans
cosmetics pleasure boats worth over a
million dollars orange juice corn
whiskey and motorcycles which is about
three and a half billion dollars of US
goods not an insane amount right away
but already something that we don't want
to ignore and likely there would be more
following it and I don't know how anyone
can be surprised by this right
completely predictable and when we look
at there's already been an analysis done
of what the jobs impact would be of
these tariffs proposed by Donald Trump
the trade partnership did an analysis
and what it finds is that the tariffs
would result in a net loss of about
85,000 American jobs before you account
for the impact of the retaliatory
tariffs that the EU or Canada or whoever
else could put in place so to put it a
different way
Trump's tariffs alone would create 30
3,500 jobs they would eliminate a
hundred and eighteen thousand five
hundred jobs and that would be a net
loss of 85,000 jobs but that assumes
that no other country reacts to the
tariffs in any way to those jobs lost
you have to then add in well what will
be the job loss because Europe starts
taxing a whole bunch of American goods
at twenty five percent and a few hundred
thousand jobs are really not gigantic in
the scope of the economy at large on any
given month we gain or lose a couple of
hundred thousand jobs but if the point
of the tariffs is to protect the
American economy and to protect American
jobs if you're going to have a net loss
of 85,000 jobs that means that the
isn't doing what it's supposed going to
do so then the question is what could
happen next
and that depends on how heavy-handed
Trump would want to be because Trump
also has ways to further retaliate right
Trump says 25% tariff on steel and
aluminum and the EU says we're doing 25%
tariff now on this list of American
goods well Trump could strike back again
and say we are now going to put a tariff
on for example European cars and this is
when it really starts to get dicey
because even though lots of car
manufacturers are European many of them
are making cars in the United States
right and that's why it's not a simple
Trump tweeted a couple days ago that
it's easy to win trade wars if you
decide to put a tariff on Volkswagen for
example are you hurting the company at
its headquarters in Germany or are you
hurting the workers at its factory in
Chattanooga Tennessee and of course
you're sort of doing both but the impact
is going to be much more significant on
a worker in Chattanooga Tennessee who is
going to be much more significantly
impacted if that factory is no longer
necessary then executives working at the
main corporate office in Germany so
that's how this very quickly gets more
complex then I think Trump even has a
remote understanding of yeah John Oliver
had a great comments about the trade
wars are easy to win tweet which is that
if trade Wars are so easy to win then
everyone would just win them clearly not
everybody can win the trade wars and
that's often why why you see trade wars
not even proposed by a lot of countries
that sort of understand how a globalized
economy works and that's why I'm
wondering for a guy in Trump who claims
to have excelled at Wharton School of
Business he seems to know very little
about basic economics but that's not I
mean we've talked about the problem of
how economics is even being taught in
business schools around the country and
how problematic that is in the net you
can't really win the trade war what you
can do if you have more of a tolerance
to a loss of jobs than another country
you can try to sort of lose less than
the people you're fighting or maybe you
can stick out some losses
or to their detriment and then you can
sort of make it up it's sort of like a
big company who might say you know what
because we're so big we are going to
sell products at a loss where it's legal
to do this it's not legal everywhere and
will temporarily be hurt but we're gonna
drive our competitors out of business
and then in the long run we will be able
to actually accumulate more market share
and it'll be a really great thing that
is sort of the only way that you can in
the long term attempt to benefit from a
trade war but a lot of people in the US
if that's what Trump is trying to do and
I don't really think it is a lot of
people in the US are gonna be hurt and
even though the country might be able to
ride that out a lot of people can't
afford not to have a job for the next
five or ten years and this is so bad
that even Republican Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan says that he's concerned
about the impact on this of this and it
could do serious damage to our
relationships with other countries that
might say hey you know what let's
circumvent the United States all
together let's make alliances that don't
even involve the United States and
that's what as usual Trump doesn't
really seem to be considering yeah and
it makes sense that Paul Ryan is upset
about this because motorcycles are big
in Wisconsin yeah and that's what Europe
is going to place a tariff on the same
thing when it comes to bourbon in
Kentucky Kentucky whiskey bourbon
brother yes yes a lot of a lot of
Heartland industries for lack of a
better term would be significantly
impacted by this